hi everyone I've shown you some pure
mathematics before so I thought it would
be a good idea to show you what some
applied math looks like and I have
another exam here and this is supposed
to be an example of what you could
expect to see if you studied say
engineering mathematics it's going to
cover two topics linear algebra and
differential equations and because it's
covering these two topics neither of
them are going to be too in-depth but it
will give you sort of a view of what
both of these topics looks like and the
questions that are in here are things
that I think you can expect to see if
you major in physics math or engineering
in my opinion this isn't going to be too
hard of an exam the questions are a bit
more straightforward there are less
proofs which is one of the things I
struggle the most on in math and the
math does have a lot more applications I
will post the full exam with worked
solutions down the description so you
can download that and I hand wrote these
solutions myself this time so let's have
a look at the questions I hope me
opening this exam doesn't give you too
much flashback anxiety if you've set
lots of exams yourself but first of all
we're showing some pretty easy I guess
linear algebra questions a bit of an
overview linear algebra really deals
with lines planes and rotations it's
really useful in modeling or computing
various systems because you can make
approximations of more complicated
nonlinear systems to be linear and then
you can use any algebra on them it
really talks about how things relate to
each other in space so first we asked
about the requirement for a set of
vectors or lines to be linearly
independent of each other so to have no
redundancy there when describing a
system number two is dealing with a
matrix so that's this collection of
numbers here a matrix is an array of
numbers that in this case are used
as a transformation what is the
transformation being done by this matrix
and the answer here is that this is
essentially a rotation by a hundred and
fifty degrees in space moving on we're
asked a question compute a to 2011
essentially take that matrix of numbers
and apply it to something 2011 times now
that seems really difficult because
that's such a big power but really you
need to look at it and figure out that
okay if this matrix is rotating by 150
degrees then if you do it 12 times in a
row you're going to end up back where
you started back at the identity so
essentially a to the 12 is the identity
since 2011 is 12 times 167 plus 7 really
all you need to do is do a to the power
of 7 then were asked to create or find
the inverse of a matrix and this is our
matrix here the way that we're going to
find the inverse is by doing Gauss
Jordan elimination which essentially
means we're going to do a whole bunch of
operations on the rows and the matrix so
here we have I guess an example of how
linear algebra is used in a practical
context we have a system of linear
equations so I guess three equations in
x y&z if you look at this what is given
here is actually our a matrix before if
we look at a and we know that that is XY
and Z then we can see that these
equations here are all the coefficients
are encoded in that matrix a the system
is a times X which is just x y and z
this
our space mate Victor so that's what X
is a times X is equal to B so this here
is our victor B if we want to solve the
system of linear equations what we want
to do is solve this equation here for X
so we know a from before and we know B
because it's here if we want to solve
this it involves writing it like X is
equal to a inverse B so we know a
inverse we calculated that in the
previous question that's B so if you do
some similar row column operations on
this here you would end up with this
victor which is our x y&z solution being
able to compute actually quite large
systems of linear equations becomes
really useful in engineering or lots of
other disciplines and you might find
yourself doing it much more on the
computer on something like MATLAB then
on paper pen and paper but it's good to
be able to know and understand what's
happening behind the scenes when you ask
MATLAB to solve a system for you we're
moving now into the differential
equations part of the exam and we're
dealing over here with partial
differential equations often abbreviated
to PDE s so these partial differential
equations involve an unknown multi
variable function and it's partial
derivatives we're asked here to write
down the heat equation and any initial
and boundary conditions needed to find a
unique solution this here is the heat
equation and it pretty much tells you
about the distribution of heat and space
over time again very useful in a lot of
engineering applications then we've got
some more I guess conceptual questions
about PDE s the heat equation and
boundary conditions so talking about the
physical meaning of some boundary
conditions in this case I believe
they're talking about if spatially at
the edge
of your distribution your boundary
conditions are zero physically it
implies you've got total insulation at
those end points here we've got a
similar thing asking about the heat
equation but also the wave equation
which is similar in a lot of ways except
that it describes the movement of waves
through space and then we've got these
questions that are asking you to show
that certain solutions satisfy certain
differential equations so in this case
you're asked to show that this value of
U fits within here and then it works out
again a very similar problem here just
being asked to find out U of T and UX so
we're doing a couple more partial
derivatives and finding out that they
are consistent with this equation here
is the I guess longer and more difficult
PDE question in this exam but it's
something that you'll definitely face if
you're doing a lot of PDS and really
we're given a differential equation and
we're given a whole bunch of initial and
boundary values and we're asked to find
a formal solution so the first thing
that you do in a question like this is
actually use separation of variables so
we take what we've been given which is U
of X T so we've got you in two different
variables and what we want to do is find
a V another function of X and T it's our
solution that can be described as a
function of x times a function of T a
product solution if you will if we can
separate out separate out our problem
into this then it means we've separated
our partial differential equation into
two ordinary differential equations and
those are going to be much easier for us
to solve I won't go through all the
details here but of course you can
download this full solution and the
description so I encourage you to do
that
many people watching this video may be
considering studying or are currently
pursuing engineering math and physics if
that's the case and you want to teach
yourself these ideas or you've seen the
content before and find these questions
a bit daunting then you should check out
some courses on brilliant org you master
the concepts by solving fun challenging
problems you're guided to break down a
problem into its component pieces think
clearly through each part and then build
back up to a conclusion
brilliant can walk you through courses
on both linear algebra and differential
equations as well as lots of other math
and science topics this exam might look
a bit easier when you truly understand
how these concepts relate to each other
if you are considering studying
engineering math or physics go to
brilliant org slash Tibby's and sign up
for free also the first 200 people that
go to that link will get 20% off the
annual premium subscription
thanks for liened for supporting my
channel and thank you for watching I'll
be down in the comments answering as
many questions as I can